one evening after watching the nightly
news with my then five-year-old son he
asked me a question I thought I would
have a ton of time to answer I thought
the complicated questions typically came
at 8 or 9 years old but my son looked me
in the eyes while I was tucking him in
and with a very straight face
he asked me daddy why did you go to jail
my wife and I often thought about this
moment we knew this question was coming
and we wanted to head a little well but
that night I had a question to answer so
I decided to tell my son how I ended up
going to prison when I was just a 15
year old kid this picture was taken when
I was 14 years old that's my mom my
sister and that cute little baby that's
my niece she's 23 now and it drives me
crazy every time I think about how old
I'm getting this was the last photo dad
took just a few weeks before I made the
worst decision of my life a friend of
mine and I we approached a man sleeping
in his car pulled out a gun demanded the
keys to his car and sped off that
decision landed me in front of a judge
with my mom and my sister standing just
a few feet behind me as they listened to
me you're sentenced to eight years in
adult maximum-security prisons this is
the next family photo that I took with
my mom but this time it was taken in a
prison visiting room
don't let the waterfalls and the trees
and all that stuff in the background for
you this was one of the hardest times of
my life in fact for the first two years
I battled depression by living in denial
about my prison sentence I will commonly
say things to my mom like
I'm a mom I know you don't think that
this judge is really gonna keep us here
through Christmas and then Valentine's
Day and then the last day of school and
then the first day of school and on and
on I promised my mom that one day
someone would see that I was drowning in
those cells that someone would tell us
that we could breathe again because they
just wanted to teach me a hard lesson
but one day as I'm walking around the
prison record with my friend Danny B I
asked him how long have you been here he
told me he had already served 31 years
my par was immediately got sweaty heart
dropped down to my toes and it hit me
like a ton of bricks because that's the
moment when I realized I would have to
serve all eight of my years now the
story of going to prison as a teenager
is not an uncommon one before my family
this was the most tragic thing that had
happened in our lives I missed my family
terribly and just like every other
teenager I just wanted to open up gifts
on Christmas morning and gradually from
high school with my friends and because
of the intense security in prisons
internet access is limited there's no
easy emailing no texting and definitely
no social media this means that the
meaningful moments like prom night or
college graduation or the tons of free
content that you and I digest every day
very seldom gets shared with the cousin
sibling or best friend in prison I
became very dark my childhood and the
dreams of it
they disappeared and those slamming
steel doors clanking shut every night in
a prison housing unit they forced me to
grow up fast
I can tell you firsthand that there's
something about the violent cards of
prison that completely [ __ ] hope I
even tried to push my mom away because I
didn't want her to be subject to the
collect calls the eight-hour drives for
the one-hour visits those horrible body
cavity searches that she would
experience coming to the prison visiting
room but as many of you parents here to
know know tonight that you can't stop a
mother's love so what did my mom do she
made a promise while sitting in a prison
visiting room she promised that she
would write me a letter or send me a
picture every day from that day forward
until I came home I had six years left
to do in the sentence our lives were
completely crumbling around us and here
comes this happy-go-lucky lady
prancing into a prison visiting room
like I'm in summer camp with a new plan
to send me a bunch of pictures such an
interesting time little did I know it'll
be my mom's letters that saved my life
my mom would take pictures of a
cheeseburger or a mattress at a
department store and she would send them
to me along with the letter with a
promise that one day I would enjoy a fat
juicy burger or sleep on a comfortable
bed my mom assured me that there was
life after prison in fact my best
friends began living vicariously through
my mom's letters and photos giving an
entire prison unit a glimpse into what
was happening in the world after eight
years of nightmares of prison never
ending being dehumanized strip-searched
watching people get wheeled down the
prison walkway in body bags
I was finally released and I bet you
can't guess who was there to pick me up
that cold morning in February okay you
guessed it my sister and my mom the
years that we pray for were finally in
front of us
and the pain of living behind bars was
behind us and so we thought like me
most people are prison are coming home
one day and unlike me many don't have
the consistent support during and after
incarceration that I had the struggle is
real in even I struggled to find a job
when I came home each application that I
filled out from grocery stores to
mortgage companies to fashion retail
they all included the same question
glowing pulsating waiting for me to add
my check have you ever been convicted of
a felony now to be honest I knew that
this moment was coming and I knew I
would have to face this issue so I
leveraged the mental toughness that I
built while going through prison but
after being declined for over 40 jobs
even I began to feel deflated I thought
that that I would give my life back and
that all those things were behind me and
things will start looking up but that
decision that I made when I was a 15
year old kid continued to haunt me even
up until that moment but while on the
job hunt one day I ran across an
application that asks the question but
this time it was worded a little
differently this time the question X
have you been convicted of a felony
within the last seven years now after
doing an eight-year prison sentence
I could honestly say that my conviction
was over seven years ago I was able to
answer that question with an honest no
and finally I landed my first job I was
the guy who mixed paint at the paint
store and eventually customers will come
into the store and they would ask me hey
Marcus how much do you charge to paint
my kitchen I'm like well miss Johnson we
don't paint kitchens we sell you the
paint's that you can paint your own
kitchen a light bulb went off and I
launched a painting company that became
the conduit between the customers in the
paint store and the painters who needed
consistent work after a year so I left
that painting come I left that paint
store we grew our contracting company
and since then I have hired tons of
other returning citizens I stand today
with a felony and just like millions of
others around the country who had also
had that f1 HS that represents felony
just as my mom promised me many years
ago I wanted to show them that there was
still life after prison I started living
my best life and I couldn't believe that
I was living on a cloud but my friends
the same ones I grew up with in
ourselves they would call me in
constantly eggs for pictures of this new
life I was living if I travel they
wanted pictures when I got married they
wanted pictures but I didn't have the
time or the bandwidth to sit and write a
letter or print pictures for my phone I
will commonly tell them do if I could
just text you my life would be so much
easier and after searching the App
Store's
for a solution to this problem and not
being able to find one we launched flick
shop I kid you not
did you know that the prison phone
business created a billion dollar
industry some of these businesses are
predatory and so we knew we had to
figure out how to disrupt this space
flick shop allows our family members to
take a picture
add some quick text press sin and for
$0.99 we print that picture in text on a
real tangible postcard and mail it
directly to any person in any sale
anywhere in the country
there are millions of families that are
becoming torn apart simply because they
don't have the time to write a letter
figure out how to print a photo from
their phone make a store run to go buy a
box of envelopes and then to the post
office to go buy stamps we started by
connecting 50 families and then 100
families and then 500 families and now
today I am proud to say we've connected
over 140,000 families around the country
we even commonly receive mail that my
office overflowing my desk from people
in prison like Jason Jason says I got
about 15 postcards last night of so many
words of motivation that I had to write
to you just say thank you or George who
writes today I received about six
postcards with so much love I do not
know where this roof of love come from I
cannot believe how blessed I am to
sometimes be able to meet a child who
sends flicks out postcards today
incarcerated parents sometimes I'm able
to even go to the White House and
address the nation and talk about the
need for criminal justice reform and
this story is just incredible for me
because this wasn't always my life I
remember very vividly living in a six
foot by nine foot cell with a man that
was 22 years old and there to serve life
plus 43 years in thinking in my head
while I'm sitting in that bunk that
together we probably would die in those
cells
well I know that our era of mass
incarceration and the things that we see
on the news dealing with people going to
prison is a huge societal issue there
we all have to band together to help
solve but I am confident that if we're
very intentional about building family
connections and environments where
they're needed the most then this is a
big step in the right direction I
absolutely love this stage of my life
this chapter where I'm standing right
now but you know who's having way more
fun than me at this stage my mom I love
you mom thank you